so first of all let me start with I I
love the first season I'm really happy
to get to talk to you
um I've read that you are from Wales and
I'm just curious if that means that you
are an AFC wrexham fan oh I
I'm so into that it's been so exciting
for us my mom actually um grew up near
exim and I spent time as a child in
wrexham farmers market and it's kind of
I just can't believe it's happened still
and um yeah it's also led to that like I
think Ryan Reynolds film was one of the
the first film on Netflix to have like
Welsh subtitles
um just like an incredible thing to
happen to quite a small slightly ignored
place and also Rex and fans are amazing
so yeah I uh I he turned me into a fan
and I think that season two is going to
be amazing considering what happens what
will happen at the end yeah and it's
like I've got I know people there
because of where my mum's from and it's
just been amazing for the community and
like they've created jobs and they've
been very also like been very generous
with how they've like trained people up
through that documentary so yeah it's
fantastic we're on the same page um so
one of the things about this series is
that when you were offered the role
um you I'm just curious if you I mean
how much did you was there any debate in
your mind about taking it because it
could be a 10-year job it could be
something that you're doing literally
for 10 years yeah I kind of
I am I've always wanted to do something
where I could revisit a character I've
always kind of because you feel such a
kind of
you feel kind of a grief when you say
goodbye to them
um and so I was really excited by the
idea that I could like be with this
character for years and see her change
and also kind of be with a group of
actors for that much time like
um it's something that I hadn't done
before and you know being on stage being
in a movie being kind of one off in a
series or being in it completely from
like season to season it's it's so
radically different and so I kind of
really this was an itch I really wanted
to scratch and um yeah I can't believe
that I've got to be in a kind of a
recurring character and she's glad
you're all
um yeah
no I'm just wondering because anyway
um
yeah
you've you've learned I'm sure a lot of
skills new skills since joining the
series uh what's the one that you are
most surprised you've learned and
mastered so this is there's two the
first one was I thought I could swim and
then after my first swimming lesson he
was like okay so we need to go back to
basics and I was like oh what I thought
I could do this so now I can properly
swim which was a skill I didn't really
need no I needed to learn now I can't
believe I was ever in the city
um something I just never thought I was
gonna be able to do was the two-handed
sword fight
because I'm very unambidextrous
um and that was amazing and that came
through encouragement and the most
incredible teaching from like loads of
people within the stunt department and
my wonderful
um stunt double Rosary buttons kind of
really believing in me but also kind of
got to watch her for five episodes doing
lots of my stunts and she's a dancer and
stuff which kind of worked really well
um for me to like observe her someone
playing an elf
um so yeah to be able to do the whole of
that double-handed sword fight stunt
something I never imagined and it's so
fun
like it's as fun as you think it is like
my my inner child was just going bonkers
I loved the uh since we can talk about
spoilers season one uh talk a little bit
about filming the big reveal at the end
and how you and Charlie maybe talked
before stepping on set to you know to
talk about maybe the scene or was it one
of these things where you you didn't
talk about and you got on set and that's
where the the magic happened no we
talked about everything a lot and we had
a lot of time
um because of the weird circumstances in
which we kind of filmed this
um so no we discussed it loads and we
were so excited for it finally to happen
and
we kind of rehearsed but Charlie had
never really gone full sound on until we
were on set so that first time where he
actually was like I've had many names I
was like
never seen Charlie like that it's kind
of frightening
um it was just
um I felt like we'd kind of it made we'd
like earned that moment as well
um that I feel kind of
Charlie is a wonderful actor and also a
wonderful man who made me feel super
comfortable and I think that meant we
could like really kind of push ourselves
and create this chemistry between these
characters but then it ultimately it was
really satisfying when we saw it crumble
so it was really fun so how long did you
actually film that scene was it all in
one day
um could you talk a little bit about
that no we had like three things to
shoot kind of the first reveal and then
the bit on the raft
um and the bit on the raft was really
fun because we kind of explored loads of
different things and then kind of ended
up with that kind of screaming of two
kind of forces against each against each
other what was really funny about that
was that it was obviously like so much
secrecy
um
but like occasionally as actors you kind
of forget your lines and Charlie forgot
the line what will you what will they
say when they know that Sauron lives
because of you and called line and then
kind of Hamish the first ad on the
massive speakerphone said that
throughout the kind of booming
throughout the whole studio and Beyond
and that's very funny
um but also it's kind of
it was really fun to go back to the raft
because we'd filmed loads of that at the
beginning and it kind of was good for us
as actors that we were going back to
this familiar place
um but it was just so much fun it was
such drama it felt like Shakespearean
she left do you think there was any even
the smallest percentage of Galadriel
that was drawn in
by Sauron uh or do you think it was
completely a hundred percent you know no
chance I don't know I kind of want to
keep it ambiguous as well
um but I think the thing with Gladwell
is that she knows that should she go to
the dark side things will be
catastrophic and I kind of feel that
like I've been thinking a lot about like
what the gift of foresight like would
actually feel like and I'm like is it
just like increased anxiety in a way
because you have all these ideas of what
could be what could be what could be and
I think one of her big what could be is
is like what if I'm bad
um
but I don't know I mean they definitely
vibe because they're very powerful but
I'm not sure
when you were cast or even now
um how much did you feel that you wanted
to read everything learn everything
about Lord of the Rings because you know
you're going to run into fans that are
going to ask you like real deep
questions and how much is it sort of
like I can only you know what I mean
where's that line yeah
um
I
I really wanted to be like
very immersed in the feeling of Middle
Earth because I think that kind of a big
part of his writing isn't and isn't just
kind of about the characters but it's
about the world itself and what it means
to kind of exist within that world do
you know where
there are bell rocks and there are kind
of
um things have significance
um
um and so I just bought the cell
Meridian audiobook and kind of The Lord
of the Rings and Hobbit audio I'd never
read the silmarillion and just had them
on all the time like if you saw any of
our casts walking around or walking
around Auckland with light headphones in
they probably weren't listening to music
they weren't listening to like the
silmarillion
um and I kind of yeah just wanted to be
more immersive and now I feel like I
know quite a lot about it but I think
what's quite nice about the talking
Community is because his um because his
writing was so vast is that nobody feels
they're completely an expert on it and
it's quite a nice place to be that
everyone kind of
is happy to learn from each other and
kind of you'll be an expert in a
particular part of it say you'll meet
different people who have very different
insights and kind of the philosophy of
it as well I mean you could just talk
about it and learn about it forever and
I've started that Journey now and it's
really nice I have to go but just I have
to ask you one last thing real quick I
know you're filming season two and I am
a huge fan what can you tease about
season two and how has it been going
um I see what I can tease about season
two is
because
there's there's some very interesting
villains
coming thank you for your time and
seriously congrats on the series thank
you